The translation will then hence
go on a little bit longer.
Sometimes a little bit shorter.
But everything that we say is
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
that the prophet he's going to
die and so you'll be rid of him
sooner or later. This is what
the prophet antagonist would
say. And they forgot themselves
in this statement. Because yes
he will pass away. As he did.
But that doesn't mean that they
will inherit the inherit the
earth and and live on after him
forever. They will pass away as
well. And so, while that
statement is correct, it is
deficient in the sense of being
applicable to them. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says, and
we have not given any human
being before you. Eternity to
live on this Earth. Eternity in
the hereafter is agreed upon.
And so if you die, will they
then live on for eternity? The
answer is of course no. This is
a rhetorical question. He then
says, that which means each,
soul, each individual shall
have an experience of death.
we will test you with evil and
good
and to us you shall return.
Allah
[Silence]
this the individual? Is this
the one who? So blatantly
mentions your gods aside from
Allah. Meaning that they're
saying they're claiming that
they are gods that they worship
aside from Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala that these gods are high
and of high stature and so when
they would see the prophet they
would try to demean him and try
to poke fun at him and mock him
saying is this the one who
mentions your gods in a
negative light? Any more right
does he have to mention your
gods in a negative light? Yet,
they forget themselves elves
with this statement and they
are turned away from the
remembrance of Al Rahman and
they disbelieve in al Rahman.
Subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
The human being has been
created from haste
I will show you my signs and my
miracles. So, do not hasten me.
This statement, the human being
has been created from haste.
This is
this sentence is structured in
the way that this is structured
is in an exaggerated sense To
articulate that the human
being's nature to be hasty and
for a person too learn to be
other to be otherwise, excuse
me
for a person to be otherwise,
to not be hasteful, person has
to learn this as a skill and to
discipline himself, to not be
hasty, and they will never be
completely rid of haste. This
will always be an element in
the human being's life. Because
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells
us here, the human being has
been created from haste.
Obviously, we see in other
places in the Quran, the human
being has been created from
clay, from dirt, from dust.
This is what the is literally
created from. However, as a way
of articulating just how deeply
rooted haste and being hasty is
into the human psyche, into the
human mind. It's as if the
human being has physically been
created from haste. And so,
this is the person's nature.
And to change this, takes much
discipline. Allah sub Allah is
saying, the human being has
been created from haste. This
is a response to them when they
would say to the prophet in a
mocking town. Make thee hour,
the day of resurrection start
now. If you're telling the
truth, then, make the day of
resurrection commence right
now, right? Let us be punished
now. If you're truly a prophet,
let the let the sky fall on us
now and let the earth swallow
us up and all of these kinds of
things. They would say these
things in a mockery, in mocking
the prophet in a very antagon
way and so Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala said the human being has
been created from haste. I will
show you my signs. So, do not
hasten me. that is enough for
today.